la mobilisation des électeurs c'est bien
ce qu'espère le parti socialiste les
électeurs de gauche et du centre à la
tête du ps les divisions semblent de
plus en plus profondes françois hollande
continue de vouloir s'adresser aux
électeurs du modem a tandis que ségolène
royal attend des nouvelles du président
du modem françois bayrou
le reportage de serge cimino et de
laurent feniou les voix du modem de
françois bayrou troubles pour le mois
les stratégies du parti socialiste
souvenez-vous hier ségolène royal répond
des francos à la question avez vous
tenté de joindre françois bayrou c'est
un message un message mais pas d'assaut
est pas question d'accord avec le modem
mais de défense du pluralisme
mais françois bayrou n'a pas répondu il
s'en explique pas par sms mais ce matin
sur rtl
non je n'ai pas rappelé ségolène royal
non pas par manque de respect mais pour
éviter toute ambiguïté
autrement dit j'aurais nourrit cette
accusation qui est une accusation fausse
et injuste de ce qu'ils disent est dans
la majorité actuelle en fait ils sont
passés à gauche
de la même manière qu'à gauche il ya un
certain nombre de gens qui disent en
fait ils sont à droite
nous sommes indépendants cet après midi
françois hollande s'est chargé de
rappeler la position officielle du parti
dans les circonscriptions la gauche est
éliminé et où le modem est présent il
faut défendre le pluralisme donc battre
l'ump
il attend la même chose du modèle tout
cela lui semble ne pas être différent et
l'attitude de ségolène royal elle n'a
pas défini notre stratégie elle a
simplement laissé un message à françois
verrous en lui disant faites en sorte
que le pluralisme puissent être ici
favoriser et d'ailleurs la réponse de
france burkina pathétique téléphonique
qui a été sur la voie des ondes a été de
dire oui ne leur ont pas de consigne de
vote sur d'autres mais nous ferons en
sorte que le pluralisme ce soit favorisé
respectait pas de divergence donc entre
hollande et royal
à l'heure du bureau national de fin
d'après-midi prononcer le mot modem fait
quand même réagir avec le modem ont
changé la comédie de boulevard
la honte par une porte toujours par
l'autre déclarations contradictoires
j'arrive à tenir encore cinq jours avant
de dire ce que je pense de tout cela
voilà qui promet une belle ambiance
après les législatives